what's not protected as free speech in
the US here's a short list incitement
you can't say something that
intentionally incites
or encourages violence or breaking the
law false statements effect saying a lie
that harm someone's reputation could
land you behind bars this can be in the
form of slander or libel obscenity this
is a gray area but if the average person
would find the published material
inexcusably and offensively sexual it's
probably a no-go child pornography just
don't fighting words and true threats
personally insulting someone to provoke
them to violence then be fighting words
threats that create a clear and present
danger aren't allowed either check out
your local ACLU for more info